[Applause]
me too thank you okay let's face it
you've got this series coming out
everybody's going to be freaking out
about it this is marvel universe
oh my gosh i'm so excited um like what
where did you dig where were your
sources of confidence inspiration
you know badassery
well
i have the entire
marvel cinematic universe to look to for
some inspo um going into this
show um with jeremy renner who um plays
clint barton hawkeye uh this is somebody
who's been in the mcu for some time so
to to not only have
this person who
was the perfect person to just
completely take me under his wing and
show me the ropes i was like so ready to
go and i feel like the dynamic between
our characters clint and kate are
in ways similar to mine and jeremy's in
that i was
very ambitious and very excited and over
eager to like jump in there and like get
my hands dirty and and do the thing and
with the archery with the training it
all um
it's it's it's so amazing i love that
with what i do i get to experience
something new and learn a new skill and
pick something up that maybe i in the
past have never even like at all
considered and with archery it's
definitely become something i love and
being very present being very focused
and and those are
you know a few things that my my
character kate very much is i love that
okay now speaking of uh close figures in
your life your brother
is a race car driver a nascar driver but
i'm looking and he has the old car
um what is that called
other than the coolest i've ever seen
thank you yeah he is i mean this guy
the biggest thrill chaser you'll ever
meet but he um
drag races this this truck now uh and
yeah he's raced nascar he's raised
trophy trucks off-road
desert racing he's done the he's done it
all um started with the you know dirt
bikes and the go-karts but he's he's
made it a long way and it's so
incredible to watch him do what he loves
and i i've always been so fascinated by
how similar but different we are and um
he just it's amazing to see him in his
element because it's like so different
from mine and like not anything i could
you know ever do so okay i love this and
i hear like girls go a little batty for
him or a lot batty for him and looking
at him and he's adorable with his drugs
are you protective of him
i definitely i definitely am but
yeah
i am there's no butt
and is he protective of you
he yes
absolutely he is like
he is my my biggest
protector supporter um
champion he just is my best friend oh i
love that so much i have always
idealized siblings and i even love the
fighting when my kids fight i'm like
at least you have each other
um well earlier in the show we got into
some thanksgiving news especially food
news
and um i was wondering uh we brought a
flavored snack um and i was wondering if
you would try it with me
yes absolutely okay what is your
favorite like what is your number one
you fight people for it dish
um okay so my nana makes a stuffing that
is
pretty hard to beat
these are stuffing chips
i know i'm aware
do i try it yeah let's try it one two
three here we go
wow right
i'm not mad at it
it's not quite giving me nana's stuffing
but
it's giving stuffing okay tell me about
nana's stuffing i'm hanging on every
detail what's it like what's the what's
the ingredient um what does it taste
like okay well it's been a secret for a
long time but i've kind of gotten to the
bottom of it um but it's just so good
and i i it's always like better as
seconds you know um
put in the fridge heat up the next day
oh so good um
okay can we do a quick game with you
haley thanks no thanks let's do it okay
great i love it
thank you so much all right we wanted to
get your take on all things thanksgiving
in a game we're calling thanks or no
thanks
okay
okay i'm gonna read off a list of
thanksgiving traditions and if you're
into it say thanks and if you're not no
thanks you ready okay i'm ready okay
running a turkey trot thanksgiving
morning
no thanks thanksgiving is like you you
you sleep and then the minute you wake
up you start eating we're not running no
okay great i love it okay listen when
it's the holidays it's the holidays we
take a break
god that is so incentivizing okay
thanks or no thanks matching family
pajamas
oh thanks um leftovers for breakfast the
day after thanksgiving
absolute thanks
bringing tupperware to thanksgiving
that sounds like something i would do so
that's a thanks
um okay thanks no thanks to watching
football all day
thanks okay one last one putting up
christmas decorations on thanksgiving
day
thanks
thanks
yes
oh this makes me so happy because i want
to decorate the tree with the girls on
thanksgiving and we've never done it and
this year i was like i just want to do
it as soon as possible is thanksgiving
too early
no
we all love you so madly and dickinson
is available on apple tv plus i've been
watching it it's so fantastic you're so
magnanimous in it and be sure to fight
people in line for hawkeye which begins
streaming on disney plus november 24th
get it while it's hot haley i just love
you so much you're the best
[Music]